my name is Ava Lisa Belconnen and on
behalf of my coworker and Isis Michael
slabs and Anja Paco I would like to
welcome you all for this Centennial
symposium it is a great honor to have
president solloway join us tonight and
he will introduce tonight's speaker
Thank You Ava Lisa good evening
everybody
the way you said that it's as if we
don't know who tonight's speaker is but
I think we all have a suspicion of who
it might be and so I'm really pleased to
be here and honored to be here on this
occasion not only because of not only
because of the wonderful Yale history
that will be embodied in Dean stones
lecture and I should add the book that
accompanies with it and and and you did
a fantastic job getting this done thank
you
but also because it's really an
opportunity to celebrate the School of
Architecture and the Dean's legacy
within the school I think you all know
this has been an incredible 18 year term
it concludes in June and we are just
indebted let me say to you Bob not refer
to you in the third person for all that
you have achieved in leading the school
to the position of excellence that it
that it holds today it's been an amazing
deanship I think many of you who are
familiar with academic tradition know
that an 18-year deanship is a very
unusual event typically Dean's
serve for five and then you sort of
begged them maybe they'll do another
five and then usually after that second
five you push them out but here the the
the the 18 year tradition reflects
reflects I think I shared intransigence
that is I couldn't have been more
delighted that when I became president
Dean Stern was it's in the saddle was
one of our most experienced Dean's was a
model for others and was leading the
school I think to such great heights
we're fortunate to know that we'll be
able to build on his terrific record
with the oversight of his successor
Deborah Burke and I think many of you
know
Dean desi Lippert who's with us tonight
and we watching
before I speak a little bit to Dean
Stearns excellent eighteen years I do
want to acknowledge a few people who
have helped us particularly with the
school so to the Miller family for its
generosity and establishing the J or
when Miller fund which supports the
symposium that this lecture is a part of
to my predecessor as yells president
Rick Levin and to the fourth century
Trust for enabling the publication of
the book that chairs the symposiums
named pedagogy in place 100 years of
architecture education at Yale and as I
alluded to earlier Bob did that book
jointly with Jimmy staff who is with us
tonight to the School of Architecture
really holds a vital place within this
university and really within the world
were incredibly proud of this school and
that it plays such a leadership role in
guiding the discipline of architecture
as a whole what happens at the Yale
School of Architecture matters through
the field of architecture is important
to the world of architecture and that is
the role that a school at a great
university should play in its field or
profession as I mentioned during Dean
Stern's nearly 2 years at the helm of
the school it's been in a period of
outstanding accomplishment and growth so
for example there's been a
reinvigoration of the school's
curriculum establishing it as the center
stage of contemporary architecture
discourse there's been some terrific
fundraising success new endowment funds
totaling more than a hundred and four
million dollars that enhance our
financial aid for students that expand
the schools visiting critic system that
support international travel for
students in design studios and seminars
and ensure the continued success of the
school's ground
design/build program the gym block
first-year building project I suspect
that some of the people responsible for
some of what I just ticked off are with
us tonight and I thank you for your
support of the school the school also
under the dean's leadership has
developed an expansive publications
program enables the school the documents
studio art of its students document
faculty research and architecture
criticism under Dean Stern's leadership
there's been the implementation of a
robust and acclaimed gallery program
that features exhibitions from peer
institutions as well as ones that
originate right here at Yale and of
course we are sitting in the Hastings
auditorium of the restored Paul Rudolph
Hall a restoration project that was
carried out under Bob's
leadership that has really I think
created a renewed appreciation for
Brutalism and for this building in
particular I remember I'm a psychologist
and and not an expert in architecture
although of appreciator of architecture
and I remembered having mixed feelings
about this building until the day I went
back for the reopening and I saw the
orange carpets and I saw the mid-century
furnishings and I saw the way these
materials work against each other and I
sort of saw the whole thing
in a way that I had never seen it before
and I you know you you it's just great
having that experience as a novice where
you say I see what he was going for I
see what he was trying to do and I think
many of us had lost that and it was so
great so great to recover that in the
renovation of this building under Bob's
watchful eye so he is a man who needs no
introduction despite my having gone on
and a little bit of length there that is
cleeshay I used reluctant is reluctantly
the last time I said here is a man who
needs no introduction I was referring to
Henry Kissinger and I know Bob is
thinking that's all but who is he again
and by him but Henry Kissinger was
sitting right here and I said and now
I'd like to introduce a man who needs no
introduction and I hear the banging on
the stage of a cane and it's Henry's
cane you know he's 92 years old now and
this is about a year ago he's banging
his cane on the on the stage and he
leans into the microphone and he says
Peter I may be a man who needs no
introduction but I am also a man who
likes to listen to one so so you know
when when when you have on your sheet
here is a man who needs no introduction
you generally haven't written out and
interacted so I sort of made one up for
him on the flight but this is a man who
needs no introduction but he is a man to
whom we are so grateful so appreciative
I am proud to call him both a friend and
a fellow a colleague if we were fellow
Dean's together for a number of years
actually about seven of those years and
you have my deep gratitude you have the
deep gratitude of everyone in this room
and you especially have the deep
gratitude of the larger Yale community
we bask in the reflected glory of this
school and are so appreciative for what
you have done for it so please join me
now in welcoming our Dean Dean Robert
ooh
I shall now enjoy thank you so much
Peter Peter has an unavoidable conflict
which he already adjusted and as only
presidents of universities can get away
with but he has to take care of business
as they say I thank him so much for the
introduction and I thank you all for
coming and there are many people
watching this in other rooms I'm sorry
we can't all be in the same room
together but those of us who are Dean's
like Debra will be and I know that it's
not always possible to fill even this
room up so I'm thrilled to see you here
I want to reiterate what Peter said that
this is the kickoff for the Irwin Miller
symposium learning doing thinking
educating architects in the 21st century
which has been convened by esteemed
colleague Ava Lisa Falcon and it helps
commemorate a hundred years of
architecture education at Yale but first
I'd like to say a few words about erewan
Miller Kerwin Miller jr. when Miller BA
of 1931 had a love and respect for
architecture that took many forms
including his close collaboration with
eros Erin and with Kevin Roche whom I'm
delighted is here with us tonight on
Cesar Pelli who is also here and on many
private and public part projects in mr.
Miller's home city of Columbus Indiana
as a member of the Yale Corporation he
made sure that architecture flourished
in the university through stewardship
patronage and the support of this school
the importance of which he understood
perhaps better than anyone in the
university community in 1976 mr. Miller
wrote a distinguished school of
architecture so import is important to
Yale and to the nation Yale is concerned
more than most Univ
our cities with the conservation and the
constant Restatement of human values in
a society containing so many
dehumanizing forces architecture is
concerned with the kind of visual life
we will lead it is thus an indispensable
component of humane education and indeed
of civilized human existence as well he
went on to say that the Yale School of
Architecture continues to influence this
country to a degree quite out of
proportion to its small size it is not
an easy task which a school has to
perform the undertaking to recruit the
most talented young men and women of
each generation and give them personal
exposure to the best faculty of their
times will always be expensive this is
the pitch that he was making but I'm
happy to make it on his path to those
who can throughout them throughout man's
history however there has been no other
way to teach the best and to teach them
well such schools are generations in the
making yet can be lost overnight we are
indebted to mr. Miller's children for
the generous gift of endowment that
makes these symposia a permanent part of
Yale's architectural culture it's a
great honor for me to speak to you today
although it pains me that this will be
one of the last opportunities I'll have
to hold court at the lectern as Dean and
how I have enjoyed it this talk
this talk goes from research I conducted
with Jimmy staff who's here with us
tonight meed class of 2011 for our book
in the history of architecture on the
history of the school's architecture
pedagogy in place and the exhibition
that is now upstairs and view in the
gallery and I'll be happy to say I'm
happy to say that Jimmy and I will be
happy to sign copies of the book after
the lecture as is customary in these
things my talk today is little more than
a broad survey of the school's pedagogy
and the buildings that have housed it in
the brief time allotted I will discuss
key faculty administrators and students
who in their individual ways help
illuminate that story but to begin
please indulge me in a brief discussion
of three pedagogical models which have
dominated architecture education in the
West over the last 250 years
the first combining apprenticeship was
fought formal training is represented by
the practice of English architect Sir
John Soane who flourished in the early
19th century wanting to perpetuate
architecture as a family business a sone
began planning an Academy where his son
George was when his son George was born
in 1790 he's designed his villa could
Sanger manner as an environment to help
introduce the boy into the profession
unfortunately Little John Soane showed
no interest in architecture like my son
Nick here came here for one week doesn't
always work when you have kids let me
tell you rather than being discouraged
the eldest zone grew more dedicated to
to his legacy and established a formal
program of architectural education in a
new London home at 12 Lincoln's in field
many of you have visited it no doubt a
demanding teacher he required 12 days
from his student hour days from his
students who absorbed the language of
classicism by making carefully measured
technical drawings and elaborate
representations of ornament
usually grown from casts and sones
extensive collection one stone began
teaching at the Royal Academy his
students prepared drawings for his
lectures such as this illustration
comparing the sizes of famous domes
beginning with sones own Bank of England
and culminating in the dome of st.
Peters both zones office and the school
died with him Frank Lloyd Wright's
mother on a Lloyd Wright
Anna Ward Jones says actually called
herself was more successful in setting
her infant son on a path toward becoming
an architect she surrounded his baby
room with engravings of gothic
cathedrals nearly a hundred years after
sones death Frank Lloyd Wright would
adopt the idea of an academy built
around the work of a single master
establishing his own school at Taliesin
in Arizona in 1932 and in Wisconsin both
a second model the Polytechnic is best
represented by the bow Academy in Berlin
which treated architecture as a matter
of tectonics and prepared students to
serve the state as engineers the bow
Academy evolved into one of the most
influential architecture schools in
Europe particularly after called
Friedrich Schinkel
a former student at the bow Academy
designed a new technically
straightforward brick structure to house
the school completed in 1836 the bow
Academy would have a significant if
limited influence on American
architecture most notably at the
University of Illinois and
urbana-champaign through the remarkable
career of Nathan Ricker as a student in
1870 Ricker working under bow Academy
trained architect Harold Hanson crafted
an architecture program based on
mathematics and technical drawing Ricker
would go on to fan
and leave the new architecture
Department so he's the holy God
architect who was a student who then
went on to become the foreman to run to
create the department obviously a man of
great genius and energy Ricker Ricker's
program adhere to the tectonic approach
of the Polytechnic and to realistic
considerable extent does the school does
so to this day beginning in the 1930s
the pedagogy that the German emigres
Mies van der Rohe brought to the
Illinois Institute of Technology closely
echoed that of the BAU Academy and
Ricker and an Ricker Kevin Roche once
told me that he'd gone to the study with
Mies Minh coming to the United States
from Ireland and I said why how long did
you stay he said I stayed one year I got
it
the third pedagogical model and the ones
who have had the most profound impact on
Yale and on architecture and education
in the United States in general was that
of the French Ecole de bazaar with roots
in 17th century royal patronage the
history of the Ecole is somewhat
convoluted but by the early 19th century
it had evolved into what many consider
the greatest school of architecture in
history from 1839 onward the Ecole was
was like the bowel Academy headquartered
in a central building that reflected its
pedagogy the Palais JJ dude designed by
Felix dubov incorporated architectural
fragments into the facade making the
building itself elect elector in
architectural history a lector or a
lesson that continued on the interior
much of which was dedicated to the
exhibition of large-scale plaster casts
students at the bows are studied
construction and mathematics as at the
bow Academy but the principal thrust of
the program was on the history of
architecture on composition and formal
language
I'm sure Barry bergdoll will illuminate
and probably correct me tomorrow in the
symposium Mike's own students those at
the bows are were trained to draw
beautifully to measure and represent
existing buildings to recreate impartial
evidence destroyed works of the past but
they were also required to take on their
own individual projects according to
programs prepared by the school
initiating them with designs sketched in
a cubical typically over a 12 hour
period and then developed over three to
six months in 1846 Richard Morris hunt
was the first American to study at the
occult limos are when he returned to the
states in 1855 he established a
short-lived New York Atelier modeled and
what he had experienced in France
inspiring one of his students William
Robert
to establish America's first frog formal
program in architecture at MIT in a
newly created institution itself in 1865
ironically though MIT was a School of
Engineering which it remains to this day
where's architecture program was modeled
on that of the bows are which were 75
years dominated American architectural
education with most programs housed as
at MIT in engineering schools Yale
though a comparative late comer among
its peers followed a distinctly
different pattern with a program
developed in a school of Fine Arts
founded in 1869 as the first such school
situated in an American institution of
higher learning as founding director of
the School of the Fine Arts the noted
Landscape Architect the painter rather
John Ferguson we're deliberately modeled
Yale on the Ecole des Vosges are
adopting the name School of the Fine
Arts as a literal translation of the
French institutions thing from the
beginning architecture at Yale was seen
as an artistic pursuit rather than a
technical discipline the new year school
was intended as a school of painting
sculpture and architecture all in one as
well as an art museum
we're whose brother had attended the
Ecole believed that the greatest benefit
of the French schools methodology was
the studio system which in his view
included are in contrast to many other
architecture programs which were housed
in retrofitted spaces originally built
for other purposes for example the
studios at Penn were for many years
housed in a former dental clinic torture
is torture I suppose we're was fortunate
to be able to situate his newly
established art school in a building
specifically designed for its
pedagogical purpose
Studios a library and gallery space a
lack of funds initially prevented the
establishment of a full architecture
program at Yale but in the late 1870s as
post-war civil war Yale College evolved
from a prevent provincial College status
dominated by religious studies into a
multidisciplinary research university
courses in drawing and architecture
history began to be offered to
undergraduates however would be
architects in Yale college such as James
gamble Rogers Grover nor Atterbury and
Williams Adams Delano were nonetheless
forced to supplement their studies
elsewhere typically at Columbia in order
to prepare for the rigorous entrance
examinations of the Ecole des Vosges are
a larger course of study on architecture
was established at Yale in 1980 thanks
to the testamentary bequest of Professor
James M Hoffman but it was not until
1916 that the program developed into a
full department within the school
hence today's centenary celebration from
its beginning the location of the
architecture department inside the
School of the Fine Arts made it
different from all other American
programs because the presence of
painting sculpture and architecture
students under one roof enable
collaboration between disciplines
exemplified by the introduction of the
correlated design problem which required
an architecture painting and sculpture
student to work together on a single
design and innovation likely modeled on
a similar studio and at the recently
founded American Academy in Rome
of course the architecture students
would do would design the building and
they really only one of the painters
just sort of come here something on the
wall and the sculptors to put a little
plaque nonetheless the term
collaborative would later be adopted in
Yale's program and become nationally
famous and a hallmark of the school from
the 1920s to the late 19th
as you can see in these photos taken
around 1950 in 1916 Everett Victor Meeks
was named the first chairman of the
newly formalized architecture department
a graduate of Yale College and the
occult Abaza Meeks had worked for career
Hastings in New York the Hastings of
this very auditorium and had taught at
Cornell in addition to serving in the
first architecture chairman after took
1922 he also served as dean of the
School of the Fine Arts responsible for
all its programs which by then also
included drama and art history as well
as the art gallery for over 20 years and
by the way I wanted to outlive Meeks but
that's not possible in the job I was I
don't know how he did it it was amazing
for over 20 years Meeks was not only a
powerful force at Yale but also the
leading advocate of the Bozarth system
in America when the United States
entered the first world war
just after Meeks was appointed Meeks
served in France when he returned from
Europe he was convinced that the bows
are as an institution would not be able
to recover its glory in the aftermath of
the war and that Yale as the only
American school to combine
multidisciplinary training in the arts
could become not just the American
equivalent of the air cold limos arc but
the French schools successor under Meeks
Yale adopted French methods to American
practice and quickly established a
reputation for excellence joining with
other national architecture programs to
prepare a survey in the new york-based
Bazar Institute of design which prepared
and subsequently judged competitive
design problems establishing thereby a
national standard for architectural
education recognizing that New Haven was
not exactly a major center for
architectural discourse in those years
but near enough to New York to
the best talent on a short-term basis
Meek's established an early and informal
version of the visiting critic system
that by the 1940s would become one of
the defining characteristics of Yale's
pedagogy
while many peer institutions such as
Harvard and Yale imported French
graduates of vehicle to serve as design
professors Meeks believing that these
resident Frenchmen had little
understanding of American practice
prefer to hire American graduates of
vehicle they bought Mozart who were
active as practicing architects as a
result Yale perhaps more than any other
school intertwined artistic and
professional leadership as its
pedagogical goal pursuing it a pursue a
goal pursued to create leaders in the
practice of architecture initially Meeks
who maintained a small practice in New
York was in charge of the advanced
design studios but when he became Dean
he surrendered this responsibility to
Otto phaeton head designer in the office
of James gamble Rogers and the man
generally credited with the design of
Harkness tower Phaeton a graduate of MIT
and the Ecole des Vosges are proved to
be both a brilliant teacher and a
colorful character in beloved as a bib
ulis gentleman who according to students
was best in his cups which likely led to
his departure from Yale in 1933 which is
rather sad that's just when booze became
legal again fail fan completed his
teaching career at Penn interestingly
enough which remained a solid we BOS our
institution until the 1950s with failed
his departure Meeks brought in raymond
hood a surprising but inspired choice
hood was one of the most open-minded and
stylistically progressive architects in
america Meeks found in hood a perfect
response to the increasingly vocal
requests for a more modern approach but
his bows are training put the
conservative Meeks at ease a leading
skyscraper architect meet hoods Daily
News and McRoy old buildings as well as
Dobbs Ferry apartment tower project were
included in Hitchcock and Johnson's
groundbreaking 1932 exhibition on modern
architecture hood the first American
architect of consequence to take
Micawber Jay's work seriously in
particular his ideas about urban design
brought to Yale a cosmopolitan modernism
grounded in American pragmatism
regrettably hood died in 1934 aged 54
forcing Meeks to search for someone of
comparable stature who could respond to
students demands for a curriculum that
addressed a rapidly changing culture
demands brought about by the Great
Depression and by the dramatic
pedagogical changes taking place after
1936 at Harvard which established its
suppose our curriculum in favor of a
modernist program led by Walter Gropius
Meeks was personally reluctant to
embrace anti historical modernism as
Harvard had but he understood the need
for change after a few laccoliths
mustered interim appointments in 1938 he
found his perfect successor to hood in
Wallace K Harrison who in turn brought
with him to teach at the school a German
Swiss architect who had worked for luck
or busy name his name was Oscar michka
Harrison and Nitschke who were in close
contact with French modernist artists
brought a welcome cosmopolitanism to the
program encouraging innovative thinking
in design in 1939 Meeks expanded the
curriculum to include a program in City
Planning led by architect planner
in Parsons a graduate of Yale and the
bows are unfortunately Parsons died
shortly after the appointment but
students George Dudley and Maynard Myer
decided to remain at Yale after
graduating in architecture to work under
Harrison to organize the planning
program when Meeks became chairman in
1916 Street Hall home of the art school
was 50 years old and hopelessly
overburdened thank God kept one year no
slipped away well it'll come up yep
there it is
and obviously overburden as a result he
immediately began to lobby the
university for funds to expand the
school's facilities a court in a court
to a master plan designed as a thesis by
a student I'm an eye feldman class of
1920 as a result of Meeks is lobbying
and Feldman's inspired conception of the
school's future the university agreed to
relocate the architecture department
into an unfinished building which was
completed and renamed we are all in
honor of the school's founding
directorates now at the back of the
courtyard a behind the Art Gallery it's
not part of Jonathan Edwards College
also called for in the Feldman plan was
an expansive new art gallery which was
partly realized in 1928 freeing Street
Hall for the excuse exclusive use of
painting and sculpture students James
gamble Rogers was initially approached
to design the new museum but the
Commission was ultimately awarded to
another Yale College graduate education
swore trout who developed a grand
Romanesque inspired scheme for a
building spanning an entire block in
this early image of the skull of the
building you see the sculpture Hall on
the lower right and in it you see
Minerva goddess of wisdom and craft who
would really later as
centerpiece of the art and architecture
building in the department's early years
many of the students came from Yale
College like the multi-faceted George
Nelson class of 1928 who wandering into
we're Hall one day to get out of the
rain
was it awestruck by the student drawings
on display later on being me so tell him
as drawings were terrible but they
impressed Nelson who went on to win the
Prix de Rome and joy and enjoy a
celebrated career as an architect
journalist and designer in 1938 when
arson convened a conference of housing
experts at Yale to discuss the latest
technical developments in the field
nelson designed the accompanying
exhibition the first of many he would
design in his long and productive career
by no means that all the early students
come from Yale College again we are
class of 1931 was the school's first
Chinese student and after graduating
liang went on to become Frank Lloyd
Wright's first apprentice at Taliesin
where by day he worked on the farm and
designed under the master and by night
entertained the fellowship with violin
concertos Eero Saarinen class of 1934
also came from an atypical background as
the son of the eminent finnish architect
Eero Saarinen designer and director of
the Cranbrook Academy a campus
comparable in Rome in romanticism and
urbanity to Yale's recently completed
Harkness memorial quadrangle after a
year studying sculptor in Paris aro was
admitted to Yale on the basis of a
letter his father wrote to Dean Meeks
asking of his under credential son could
enroll
admission was quite a bit easier in
those days Meek's accepted Orioles boy
immediately a wise decision
Eric what quickly proved his mettle as a
brilliant draftsman and designer winning
numerous awards and exhibiting a mastery
of both traditional and modern styles
other notable students of Meeks is mill
middle years include donald mclaughlin a
classmate of Saturninus who is best
known as the designer of the United
Nations logo or harold rome BFA 1934 who
went on to success as a broadway musical
composer and leslie cheek jr a harvard
college graduate who came to Yale
because of the architecture departments
close collaboration with the drama
department for which he would design
sets cheek would go on to a leading
career as a museum director known for
his innovative exhibition design world
war 2 pretty much ground the department
to a halt when Meeks reached mandatory
retirement age in 1947 Charles Sawyer
was appointed dean though Sawyer came
from amuse the museum world he had good
instincts regarding art and architecture
education and secured the services of
George Isle as chairman of the
department of architecture and former
Bauhaus master Josef Albers as chairman
of the Department of Art George Howell
was an ideal choice to help Yale with
the transition from the bozo era to
architectural modernism because he had
made the same traditional transition
himself the occult of all those are
trained now began his career designing
widely admired traditional country
houses before partnering in the late
1920s with William musk as to design the
Philadelphia saving fund society
remind mark 20th in 20th century
modernism at the time of his appointment
how was one of the most prominent
american-born architects associated with
the modern movement Albertson now became
great friends and comrades in arms each
helping the other transform their
respective departments into ones more
reminiscent of those found at the much
admired Bauhaus the German School of
Arts and Crafts and industrial design
found it as you all know by Walter
Gropius at the time how an Albers
embarked on reforming Yale's curriculum
and the and the profession the public
and had come to regard Harvard's
Graduate School of Design then still led
by Gropius as the American Bauhaus to
fight the fact that Harvard had no
programs in painting none in sculpture
or design not much of a Bauhaus it seems
to me
Yale on the other hand with programs in
all the arts naturally seemed better
suited to take on the mantle of the much
admired but defunct German school in the
wake of World War two as GIS flooded
into Yale temporary architecture duties
where studios were established in the
gallery sculpture hall and in nearby
storefronts searching for a more
permanent solution it was decided to
expand the art gallery not according to
the originally intended design but with
an entirely new entirely modernist
edition designed by a relatively obscure
faculty member who had mentored Louis
Icahn a classically trained modernist
from Philadelphia
the art gallery extension was cons first
substantial project it was also the
first modern building at Yale it opened
in 1953 providing class room workshop
and studio space for both art and
architecture students
who could study in a building that
significantly contributed to the
redefinition of modern architecture in
shaping Yale's new curriculum in
architecture how relied on three very
different architects who can be seen as
representing aspects of his own personal
philosophy Philip Johnson the designer
historian Brewis Khan the artists
philosopher and Eugene now the primitive
Isildur in the 1950s all three men had
an extraordinary influence on students
Johnson though perceived to be an arch
modernist introduced issues of the past
famously shocking students with the
admonition you cannot not know history
on the assumption that style was
all-important Johnson in full rebellion
against his Harvard education under
Walter Gropius asked students to design
a house in the manner of Frank Lloyd
Wright then to design it in the manner
of the Corps visit then to design it in
the manner of Mies van der Rohe and then
at the end of the term there was a short
moment when the student could turn to
his own resources here you see Duncan
Buell's house in the manner of Frank
Lloyd Wright Buell class of 1953 would
go on to become one of those times
chief associates in addition to Johnson
how relied on Lewis Kahn who arrived at
Yale in 1947 actually before I was
appointed and with his arrival was
something of an accident virtually
unknown he was called in as a
last-minute replacement for Brazilian
architect Oscar Niemeyer as an avowed
communist Niemeyer was prevented from
teaching by the United States government
it was Conn who had first proposed how
it's the new chairman Cohn was like a
guru was a guru like teacher fond of
opaque aphorisms but as a former student
of pole craze at Penn he was also
thoroughly imbued with bozo pedagogy
and thereby both willing and able to
rejuvenate yo stagnant collaborative
studio teaching alongside Albers and
Johnson God made sure that architecture
painting and sculptor students worked
with modern forms and materials and
worked together
if Khan was the guru Eugene now class of
1948 was the cult leader one of the more
misunderstood personalities in the
school's history now initially trained
as a cabinet maker before military
service in World War two while
recovering from injuries sustained
during the war he applied to Yale and
though he was less than credential had
no famous and had no famous father to
make a phone call gained nieces support
based on the strength of his drawing
skills later I work closely with now in
preparing a new core curriculum
eventually of empowering him with
complete control over the first two
years of the program now all favored
natural materials like stone and timber
and students were often required to show
how trees would be cut down and
processed to realize their designs in
fact now would work with students over
the summer to develop all the programs
and it was in both a deep exploration
and a very restrictive approach here you
can see the Lyman house in Malibu my
friend Lyman was a graduate of this
period the house is 1960 it perfectly
reflects
nas primitive Asst pedagogy how not only
invigorated and to an extent transformed
the curriculum he also dramatically
expanded the department's impact on the
discipline most notably by founding and
helping to fund perspective the Yale
architectural journal from the
publication of its first issue in 1952
perspective perspective student editors
have gathered historical and
contemporary material in
ongoing effort to shape architectural
discourse protect prospective has never
pushed any single agenda as how famously
put it to all architects teachers
students prospective offers a place on
the merry-go-round high was forced to
retire in 1954
regrettably his hand-picked successor
Paul Schweiker lacked the charm and
leadership capabilities to maintain
harmony among me and fractious and
opinionated faculty a small committee
was formed with the charismatic young
art historian Vincent Scully playing a
key role and in his search for a new
strong design leader the 40-year old
Paul Rudolph immediately impressed the
selection committee with his clarity of
vision and dedication to Architecture
based in Florida Rudolph was widely
known as a stimulating studio critic and
had been invited to segi succeed Mies
van der Rohe at IIT but declined to
accept the position because he would
have felt too beholden to Mises pedagogy
in 1958 when he took over as chairman in
the renamed and reorganized Yale School
of Art and architecture Rudolph's
professional career hitherto almost
exclusively focused on residential work
was taking off with major projects such
as the Jewett Art Center and Wellesley
College both as an employer and a
teacher Rudolph was an exacting
taskmaster alternately feared and loved
his dedication to architecture was total
as Alan Greenberg has put it with only
slight exaggeration there was no man
Paul Rudolph there was just architect
Paul Rudolph arguably the most dynamic
challenging and important architectural
educator of the time
Rudolph led Yale to international
acclaim regularly gathering diverse
to serve as studio teachers and design
jurors selected for the unique and often
conflicting points of view but it was
Rudolph's own words that set the course
for students own work I should have said
who saw him as a hero architect
struggling to move architecture forward
by synthesizing the lessons of the great
modern masters while also holding
contemporary architecture up to the
standards of the past
Rudolph's impact on students was
electrifying everyone tried at least
once to imitate the new chairman
including Stanley Tiger Minh presenting
his thesis for an apartment tower in
Chicago and der Scott whose project for
housing owes a career debt to Ralph's
design for married student housing your
Yale went too far there's discuss
project two Englishman Norman Foster and
Richard Rogers during their 1961 to 1962
year in the graduate postgraduate
master's class were also deeply
influenced by Rudolf especially by his
open manner and his energy above this
photo of Foster and Rogers is the mega
structural design they prepared under
Rudolf as a proposal for the Pearson
Sage Science Complex what we call
science still anecdotally we call it
that then being designed by Philip
Johnson though they were dazzled by
Rudolf Foster and Rogers found an
intellectual mentor in surge to Maya
Rudolph's complete opposite whom he had
brought to you to focus on research
level design here we see a plan for a
new city completed by Foster Rogers and
two others studying under surge jamya
Rudolph's greatest legacy was his
masterpiece the accountant compromising
art and architecture building for which
he was both architect and talent and in
which we sit tonight reviving the
pedagogical vision of John Ferguson
we're to teach all the final
under a single roof the art and
architecture building this um somehow
these things just get bad I'm having to
have their own genius well maybe no
Thank You Jimmy
yes somehow we got those out of Mordor
reviving the pedagogical vision of John
Ferguson we're to teach all the fine
arts under a single roof the art in
architecture building was a complex
spatial array of Studios crafted to
accommodate the various disciplines but
arranged in a composition of
interpenetrating volumes intended to
foster an interdisciplinary exchange of
ideas between students Rudolph hoped the
proximity of the Arts would bring a
common understanding unfortunately it
had quite the opposite effect Rudolph
had consulted with Albers and planning
the building but a lot had changed in
the five years it took to design and
build the a a a revolution in the art
and arts that occurred an Albers
conception of painting as a controlled
act on a small square canvas had become
outdated students were working on
gestural wall size canvases or throwing
painting on canvas on the ground which
Albers called smear or I by the way a
group of student artists refused to work
in the building and excise themselves to
a satellite studio at the building's
formal dedication on November 9th 1963
two weeks or so before President Kennedy
was assassinated German born English
architecture historian Sir Nicholas
Messner gave the keynote address
delivering a not so thinly veiled attack
on the design and on Rudolf prestigious
tudents to avoid imitating the new
building or its architect
it was a quite a talk Rudolf was deeply
hurt and at that moment decided to leave
the school not surprisingly indeed to
quit teaching altogether Paul Rudolph
left on June 30th nineteen thirty sixty
five about the time when it was when
what is referred to as the 60s really
began Rudolf was succeeded by
little-known West Coast architect
Charles Moore whose Casper milquetoast
official portrait bolide his soon to be
performed a persona into hipster Charles
Moore Moore's appointment coincided with
rising student activism that resulted in
a disciplinary shift from heroic form
making toward a historically and
contextually referential approach that
would come to be labeled post-modernism
amidst the tumult of the late 1960s on
the campus here at Harvard Kent stayed
columbia first Moore was depending on
whom you ask either the best man for the
job or the absolute worst certainly he
was his was a very different sensibility
from Rudolf's as is evident in their
houses and in the press they received
rudolf spatially complex New Haven
residents on High Street was published
in vogue in 1960 to photograph during a
stylish and carefully staged cocktail
party Moore's New Haven house was
presented in Playboy also carefully
staged as a swinging pad replete with
lounging models that wasn't his taste
more at little love for the art in
architecture building which he deemed to
be overbearing when in 1960 what in 1963
was admired as the supreme symbol of the
hero architect had by 1968 become the
symbol of the architect as social
oppressor more permitted students to
construct their own workspaces
transforming the architecture studio
into a virtual favela as we see as we
see in these pictures by Roy Berkeley
that sent shockwaves through older
alumni and the profession when published
in architectural form in 1967 when asked
why he allowed students to treat the
building so poorly more dryly replied it
has occurred to me for some time that an
architecture school was a place where
people were trying to be architects so
he said more did more than just combat
Rudolf's building he also redirected the
curriculum in recognition of a broader
definition of architecture and the role
of Architects in society he encouraged
students to pursue pursue experimental
design research and construction methods
and initiated several key programs that
are still central part of the school
including the independent research based
meed program which in its formative
years was largely shaped by students
like William Mitchell who helped
organize at Yale
one of the first symposiums on the use
of computers in architecture and would
go on to become dean at MIT Donald
Watson another key member of the first
meed class would later lead the program
for years before becoming Dean and Vince
Lee a polytechnic more principally
focused on the core studios encouraging
students to experiment with new building
materials as I said such as the foam
houses built under the direction of
Felix Drury they were built on the Yale
golf course one
his first faculty hires drew ease
breweries experimental projects were
embraced by many students students still
imbued with the department's traditional
emphasis on form making and the
importance of building but some believe
that that time would be better spent on
more socially relevant design and
planning projects in response to these
growing concerns more introduced what is
now known as the Jim flock first-year
building project which took students and
faculty out of the classroom and into
the job site to design and construct
real projects that address pressing
community needs you see him digging
ametrine in that photo even more got
into the act here are some recent
burling's in the program the program
started in rural Appalachia but since
1989 students have worked with nonprofit
developers to build an affordable house
every year in New Haven where their work
is desperately needed
and usually appreciated the late 1960s
was tumultuous
architecture students who were
particularly vocal in challenging
Authority commissioned a countercultural
monument from Klaus Oldenburg a Yale
college graduate I might point out and
staged various protests in opposition to
a lack of financial aid familiar theme
including a mock funeral of the unknown
a an A student and a mock auction of the
university's art collection leg as
auctioneer by John Jacobson now
associate dean
was he surprised when we found that
photo
tragically incendiary rhetoric gave way
to literal fire on June 14 1969 no one
was hurt and the fire was quickly
controlled but the damage was
significant because of the rebellious
mood of the times arson was suspected
but never proven the fire left the
building with wounds that would take
more than 30 years to heal until repairs
could be made students were spread out
across the campus chipping away at the
school's cherished cohesiveness despite
the chaos many students managed to
produce serious work and here in 1965
project for innovative modular housing
by Doug Michels and Craig Hodges who
were inspired by James Stirling and the
experimental architects of the English
Archy Graham group not everyone was on
board with such designs or with the
proclamations and manifestos that
frequently replaced solid work so what
Johnson supposedly walked out of review
saying I'm not going to look at anymore
of this ship
but that's all part of the joy of of a
diverse curriculum equal in significance
to the socially just in to the socially
responsible first-year building project
was the replacement of the masterpiece
design theses of the Rudolf error with
theme based advanced studios these can
be attributed to the influence of search
to Maya and especially to the succession
of three Studios led by Robert venturi
and Denise Scott Brown most famously
1968 learning from Las Vegas which
challenged students to analyze the
desert city as if it was room an
unorthodox assignment that offered
students a way to see the world as it is
not as hero architects would wish to
remake it the rest of the 1960s the late
60s initially pointed to a
re-examination of prevailing
architectural pedagogy but at Yale as at
most other radicalized architecture
school these reforms were never fully
implemented when the harsh political and
economic realities of the 1970s dampened
the radical exuberance of the previous
decade in 1969 the art and architecture
programs were academically separated
into two distinct graduate schools
though they still shared a building thus
bringing to rest Bazar and Bauhaus
dreams of integrated programs in the
arts a year later Charles Moore stepped
down as dean of the newly independent
school and in 1971 Hermann DJ Spiegel an
architectural engineer who had been
teaching in the department since 1955
was put in charge
Spiegel saw his role as that of a
manager responsible for getting a
demoralized program back on track beyond
the burned-out building there were
troubles in the Department of City
Planning leading to its termination
to rumors that President Kingman
Brewster was intent on closing the
entire school down there were also
productive but complicated separatist
movements within the school such as the
black workshop Hermann Spiegel did a
yeoman's job getting things back on
track but alumni late vote lobbied for
his replacement with a practicing
architect when when Spiegel stepped down
in 1976 he proposed that season falyse
succeed him
Pele who had just previously worked what
previously worked with Eero Saarinen on
the Morse and styles colleges and had
led to successful advanced studios at
Yale regarded the school as an
institution primed for positive change
working with very limited resources at a
time when the University's endowment was
barely able to cover operating expenses
tele shift the emphasis shifted the
emphasis from countercultural gesturing
to solid academics adding something that
had previously been an ethnic anathema
at Yale URI efforts were also made to
increase diversity while there were a
handful of women in the program at any
given time after World War Two in the
1970s there was a significant increase
in the presence of women students
including Sarah caples Elizabeth plated
cyber Louise bravoman and Marian wife as
well as women faculty including alumna
MJ wall and Andrea Lear's all these
changes were tracked in the pages of a
new publication retrospective which
Pelley initiated as a modest 7 page
pamphlet and has since since developed
into a robust record of student work
during this time English architect James
Stirling
first invited by Paul Rudolph to teach
at Yale in 1959 flourished as inaugural
Davenport visiting professor occupying
the chair from 1966 until 1984 the
visiting critical system was further in
strengthened with the addition of new
chaired professors ensuring that Yale's
pluralism was reinforced by visitors
teaching in the design studios under
Pelle the school encouraged a greater
just a greater freedom of aesthetic
expression than ever before and he gave
the school a great gift loss since
Rudolph's days the sense that it was the
center of architecture culture as can be
seen in this photograph of studio
critics from 1980 Charles Moore Jack
Robertson a graduate of this Rudolf era
who returned to teach King Louie Wu mark
Simon a graduate of the school under
more Fred Clark Kelly's design partner
and George Renaldo manager sees here
with us tonight a Harvard Graduate seen
holding his head in apparent pain
possibly in response to a comment by
Peter Eisenman while students were
challenged by the diverse visiting
critics they were also challenged by
their physical surroundings in 1970 the
burned-out A&A was renovated by William
de casas a former employee and student
of paul roth and renovated once again in
1974 when health considerations mandated
the removal of the building sprayed on
exposed asbestos ceilings after a
serious fire and several rounds of
ad-hoc changes the building had to say
the least
lost much of its original magic however
under Pelle and then under Tom Bibi who
succeeded him as Dean in 1985 students
began to reappear the building
chicago-based architect Tom bebe Thomas
BB class of 1965 was the first graduate
of the school to serve as its leader
despite the events of the interview
in decades BB had not much felt felt
that not much had changed since his
student days when he studied under
Rudolph and sure myath while Pepe Pele
concentrated on the advanced Studios BV
who had experienced a highly focused
undergraduate program at Cornell
before coming to Yale concentrated on
bringing greater discipline to the
introductory studios the so called core
in order to make certain that Yale
graduates had basic professional skills
while many from the post Rudolph years
which many from the post Rudolph years
definitely liked after experiencing the
read the reinvigorated core BB enables
students to choose between innovation
minded visiting critics like Frank Gehry
& burna to me and tradition based
visitors like Thomas Gordon Smith Leon
career and demetri porphyrios
significantly new courses in history
were made available such as theories of
architectural order and the architects
use of architectural history the change
in focus was startling no longer with
students just discussing the implicit
classicism of modern it modernist
architecture but we're actively
embracing the language of classical
architecture itself during this time
students also began to appreciate the
school's history particularly that of
the art and architecture building in
1988 to honor the AA's 25th anniversary
a group of students that included gilt
Schafer and Roberto de Alba initiated an
exhibition of Rudolph's drawings of the
building Rudolph was famously revolt
reluctant to visit or even discuss the
A&A after he had left Yale but at this
time he made an exception inviting the
student curators to his New York
apartment to discuss the building
the exhibition temporarily restored the
the gallery removing partitions
installed by the art school to reveal
too many for the first time a glimmer of
what the AAA building had been in its
glorious
years as had been the case with Pelle
the pressures of professional practice
led Thomas bebe to resign after seven
years I think the different phrases in
movies for seven-year itch if you
remember that movie Tom you and Marilyn
Monroe
it must be somebody old enough to
remember that movie who had States and
in 1993 Fred coder who had briefly
served on the faculty in the mid 70s was
appointed
BB's successor coder had a strong
interest in Fred is with us tonight in
urban design that affected the school's
focus including the introduction of the
urban design workshop a community
oriented planning consultancy run by
Alan pilatus it was just the right time
to return urbanism to Yale given that in
the early 1990s marked a significant
moment of transition from the
historically tense relationship between
Yale and the city of New Haven to a new
spirit of cooperation resulting from the
efforts of the newly appointed
University President Richard Levin and a
newly elected New Haven Mayor John de
Stefano while broadening the scope of
the school's interest coder also helped
lay the groundwork for an extensive
renovation of the art and architecture
building as well as other key arts
buildings school of architecture alumnus
James Cossack was hired to produce a
detailed plan for the arts area the
first such plans since Feldman's 1919
proposal for architecture students the
most critical of elements of this plan
was a partial renovation of vaa
to address the most glaring structural
and environmental problems for which a
noose glazing scheme was developed by
alumnus Fred bland was in I believe with
us tonight
with Paul Rudolph but when the interim
renovation was completed in 1994 it
became clear that a truly comprehensive
rehabilitation was
he called for Fred coders stepped down
from the deanship in 1998 but like PB
remained on the faculty after a
contentious search for a replacement I
was appointed Dean of the school those
were happy days and the FIR began to fly
with fears of an imposed traditionalist
agenda in the studios and in the matter
of the AA's expansion as illustrated by
this anonymous sketch that appeared in
my office I would have done a better job
nothing was further from my intentions
the only tradition I was dedicated to
was reinvigorating the school's
time-honored commitment to design
diversity and to the revival of the role
of its role as a crossroads of ideas a
role that I had enjoyed during my time a
student in the 1960s in 2000 the School
of Art vacated the AEA for Holcomb green
Junior Hall an existing building with a
facade credited to Lewis Kahn that was
renovated and added significantly added
onto by faculty member Deborah Burke
whom I'm happy to say will succeed me as
Dean with the art students in their own
home and thanks to a promise of funds
from Yale call alumnus Yale College
alumnus Sid bass the school was able to
make plans to comprehensively overhaul
the art and architecture building for
its own exclusive use a key component of
the project was the construction of a
new adjacent building the Jeffrey Loria
Center for art history which would
provide essential services that
Rudolph's building couldn't accommodate
Charles ultimately Charles Gwathmey
architecture class of 1962 was selected
to oversee the restoration of the A&A
and the design of Lauria Gwathmey worked
under severe time constraints design and
construction schedules were accelerated
to
meet my insistence that the architecture
program be out of the building for only
one year
given that post-professional students
were only at Yale for two years it was
absolutely critical to me that they
along with every other student
experience the AAA as a student in my
view a Yale education in architecture is
not complete without being challenged
and inspired by this building in
November 2008 as a stock market was on
it's gigantic tumble almost exactly 48
five years from the day of its
dedication the school celebrated the
completion of the restored art and
architecture building renamed Paul
Rudolph Hall at the request of Syd bass
as the aana building was restored so too
with some forgotten or neglected
cultural and academic traditions a
significant increase in endowments as
professor as president Saleh very
pointed out has made it possible to
increase financial aid to expand the
visiting critic system with new chaired
professorships to support student travel
to put other programs such as symposia
and publications on solid financial
footing courses and study opportunities
for undergraduates were also
strengthened and the school's curriculum
evolved with interdisciplinary joint
programs and in 2008 a ph.d program
distinguished by the requirement
distinguished from other programs by the
requirement that candidates be trained
and architects with at least two years
of professional experience today as
throughout Yale's history the school
seeks to balance core competence with
artistic experimentation and remains
unwavering in the belief in the belief
that the primary purpose of an
architecture school should be training
for leadership in the practice of our of
the art of architecture in many our
schools today theory is more prevalent
than history while hand drawing and
physical models have been abandoned in
favor of digital methods that encourage
even demand speculative investigation
into radical forms divorced from
tectonic Authority no ideas and
technologies are exciting and important
to the future of architecture but in
this new landscape it is it can be easy
to lose sight of the fact that the
principle purpose of an architecture
school is to prepare students for the
diverse disciplinary realities of
architecture that is first and foremost
the art of building the Yale School of
Architecture was the place where the
Bo's our model of an integrated School
of Fine Arts first came to America where
for a short time the is an
interdisciplinary dream of an American
Bauhaus flourished with a cult of heroic
for making reached an apotheosis where
the seeds of post-modernism and new
urbanism were planted but the measure of
the school has never been in the in a in
a regimented uniformity of any single
style method or ideology this is not to
say that Yale because it embraces
contradictory points of view is
rudderless far from it it means that by
exposing students to different ideas and
by testing their own ideas against those
of the past Yale has encouraged and I
believe continues to encourage students
to think for themselves as they master
the skills they need to pursue a life in
architecture while most of the leading
schools of architecture have careened
from one ism to another Yale has always
been receptive to the simultaneous
promotion of contradictory ideas while
adhering to a set of core beliefs ideals
even we believe in the value of making
things we embrace theories that are
rooted in practice we believe that
can inform new ideas and that
encouraging collaboration is just as
important as fostering individual talent
we believe in the idea of the singular
masterpiece yet we strive to create
buildings that can shape a community
above all we have an unwavering belief
in architecture as a diss deeply
humanist pursue I am grateful for the
opportunity to have shared this history
tip with you today and honored to be
part of the first hundred years of
architecture education at Yale as we
celebrate its past let us also salute
its future thank you and please join me
and others for refreshments in the
architecture gallery where you may tour
the exhibit and of course where Jimmy
staff and I will be thrilled to sign
copies of our book thank you very much